So that brings us to a so-called tournament predictor. The
idea is that you have two predictors, one is better for
some branches, the other is better for other branches. Now what
you want to do is to get the best behavior for
all types of branches. So what you want to do is,
when you have these branches, use the first predictor. When you
have these branches, use the second predictor. But you don't know
which branches are going to benefit from which of your two predictors
ahead of time. So what you really have, is
your two predictors. Let's say that they're GShare and PShare
you will use your PC of the branch to index
into both of the predictors. You will take the decisions
that they generate, and now you need to decide
which one to use. How do you do that? And
the idea of a tournament predictor is to use a
so-called meta-predictor, which is just an array of 2-bit counters.
You also use the PC to index there and
the entry of the meta-predictor does not tell you
a prediction for the branch. It tells you which
of the two predictors is the more likely to
give an accurate prediction for that branch? So what
you do is you use this to choose among
the two decisions. So pretty much this meta predictor
gives you a way to select among the two decisions
so that the final outcome is the decision, that the meta predictor thinks is a
better prediction. You train the individual predictors
just like before. On every branch outcome, you
train each of the predictors. You train
the meta predictor a little bit differently. Instead
of counting up when taken and counting down
when not-taken, the meta predictor is instead trained
on how well these two are doing. If your two predictors are both correct,
then your meta predictor doesn't change anything.
If your first predictor, like in this
case your GShare is correct, but the other one is not, then you count
down. Counting down will result in selecting
the GShare result more often. If your first
predictor is wrong, but your second predictor is right,
then you count up. Counting up will result in
choosing this prediction more often. And finally, if both
of them are wrong, then the meta predictor doesn't change
because again there is no benefit in trying to
select one over the other. So the idea of
the meta predictor is that the prediction bit of
the 2-bit counter is telling you really which of these
to select. The [UNKNOWN] is there just in
case GShare is overall the more accurate but
sometimes PShare beats it or the other way
around. And again each branch has its own meta-predictor
entry. So, this type of decision and this
type of selection is done dependant on branches, so
pretty much for here for example loop exit
branch it might be that the PShare works better.
For your correlated branches, it might be
that the GShare works better and they will
have different meta predictor entries, so that they
will use the friend predictors for their outcomes.